emily  how did you write wuthering heights  shall we begin  miss emily bronte  you're off to become a wonderful teacher  you know i don't like to meet new people  [Music]  what do you want to do  do you think i could be a writer  i have lots of stories  mr leighton will be tutoring you in  french  he speaks with such poetry any man can  speak what i want to know is can he  actually do do what  he's supposed to be an artist  so be an artist what is that i wrote it  freedom in thought freedom and thought  come on  freedom  i have often struggled to understand you  [Music]  your poetry  [Music]  do not bring shame on this house emily  did you write these it's an ugly book  there's something ungodly in your  writing  feel it when we're together  you know they call you the strange one  everyone's strange if you look at them  for long enough  [Music]  who are you  [Applause]  [Music]  you wait and see  [Music]  you